la conférence de presse de la 76e
édition du paris-nice vient tout juste
de se terminer ici à versailles pour la
neuvième année consécutive les yvelines
seront représentés pour lui parler à du
tracé je suis avec françois lemarchand
le directeur de course de paris nice
françois lemarchand est ce que c'est un
bonheur de partir à chaque fois des
yvelines mais c'est un bonheur parce que
je vais je suis un ancien coureur
cycliste et mes routes d'entraînement
c'était dans les yvelines
elles le sont toujours mais c'est plus
de l'entraînement c'est de la pratique
dominicale
donc oui sur une terre de vélo sur des
difficultés que l'on trouve un petit peu
partout et et dont les gens dont les
gens se souviennent à quand on parle de
la vallée de chevreuse ça parle à tout
le monde donc quand on peut tracer des
parcours dans la vallée heureuse et dans
le département des yvelines
c'est fabuleux quand on fait un métier
comme le mieux est-ce que vous pouvez
nous parler de cette première étape qui
se déroulera le dimanche la première
étape elle partira de château un départ
fictif jusqu'à saint germain en laye et
à la sortie de saint germain en laye un
départ réel pour aller sur sur
villepreux sur ben sur les mais nul et
on va les chercher toutes les toutes les
côtes qui sont qui sont qui sont dans
les yvelines dont certains connaissent
notamment la côte de l'es17 tournant on
va les chercher à coups de boules et les
trous on va aller chercher la coupe de
châteaufort mais côté stèle jacques
anquetil donc ça parle aussi ses démons
sont des endroits qui parle et un retour
sur saint quentin en yvelines
bois d'arcy et après on sûr du
département à la celle saint cloud ce
sera une première étape compliquée ce
serait une première étape compliquée
parce que enfin compliqué j'espère aussi
compliquée que celle que l'on a vécu
cette année à bois d'arcy fin l'an passé
à bois d'arcy puisque ça a été l'une des
plus belles étapes de
des éditions de paris nice avec le vent
la pluie et découvrir un petit peu
partout là on a fait en sorte de bad met
pas mal de portions à découvert de
n'être pas mal de difficultés donc on
espère avoir avoir avoir un aussi beau
spectacle cette année
enfin que l'an passé décidément est ce
que vous êtes inspiré du parcours
justement de l'année dernière de bois
d'arcy qui a si bien fonctionné pour
dessiner le parcours de 2018
sur cette première étape inspiré
oui et non parce que
déjà on le fait à l'envers par rapport à
l'année dernière et puis aller chercher
les difficultés on sait on sait où sont
les difficultés
donc on les propose malgré tout et
mais le gros problème c'est les coureurs
qui décident de faire la course pas si
vous avez un temps magnifique avec que
peu de vent vous aurez une arrivée au
sprint
le cas de bois d'arcy c'est
bat le contraire avant avant avant
excécrable à un temps exécrable et est
une super course donc après nous on
propose des belles choses à pression et
les comores qui dispose le deuxième
étape d'orson ville et un village de 400
habitants
c'est un choix un vrai choix oui parce
que le paris nice doit aller partout
doit partir de n'importe quel village on
sait que les grands stades sont dans les
temps dans les grandes villes
le stade 2 le stade de paris nice il
peut se déplacer dans les toutes petites
villes de 400 habitants c'est c'est une
petite commune mais c'est nécessaire à
notre fonctionnement d'aller d'aller un
petit peu partout et donc ça va faire
drôle d'avoir la caravane de paris nice
qui sera qui sera au départ d'une si
petite ville on va doubler la population
peut-être pas l'attribuer au moins la
doublait
et donc c'est bien ça on part du sud du
département tout de suite on va on va
aller dans la bosse donc encore une fois
en espèrant quai du vent qui est du vent
qui souffle d'ouest pour va pour avoir
du spectable c'est désolant si je dis ça
avec des coureurs pour les power mai
mais quelque part nous organisateurs
c'est ce qu'on sait ce qu'on recherche
aussi vous ce sera la première fois que
ce cette étape partira dans son île
première fois oui première fois dans son
ville on part souvent le lundi matin ce
sont souvent des villes étapes inédites
on est parti de condé sur vègre c'était
c'était la première fois aussi donc on
essaye on essaye de donner dans le
département dont kung fu on travaille
aussi avec le conseil départemental des
yvelines pour pour nous d'aider dans ses
choix et dans et dans ses projets mais
nous dès l'instant où on peut
s'installer ou
ou au niveau de la sécurité pour les
coureurs au niveau route si tour
correspond bien ils raison que qu'on y
aille pas donc on compte on dit beaucoup
on y va la question qu'est ce que vous
espérez pour ce paris nice 2018 moi
j'espère qu'on aura du soleil
du soleil du soleil pour la course au
soleil pour la course au soleil et puis
qu'on aura qu'on aura maintenant qu'on
aura une belle course et que les gens
répondent présents également sur le bord
de route
on a senti une nette amélioration ces
dernières années avec avec beaucoup de
public au départ ou sur les zones arrivé
au départ parce qu'on a changé notre
façon de travailler avec notre podium
signature et la présentation des
coureurs avec avec la télévision
également sur place pour valoriser
encore une fois le territoire et les
gens les gens lorsqu'ils viennent voir
les coureurs et mais ils peuvent toucher
les coureurs et donc ça c'est ça c'est
parfait donc une réussite à tous les
niveaux d'audience télé mais public
aussi sur le bord de la route parce que
quand il ya du public ça veut dire que
la course est attrayante et qu'on a on a
gagné une partie du pari merci françois
lemarchand et bon courage pour
l'organisation de ce paris nice 2018 si
beaucoup